Nicole is in Houston Texas hi Nicole
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Nicole how are you I'm great thank you
so much for asking sir thank you so much
for taking my call I am I am a new
listener a brand new and I saw a few of
the baby steps I was looking over them
and I saw that you recommend that people
do not put into their 401k on to pay off
their debt my husband is actually very
serious about his 401k and he really you
know believes I'm putting everything in
it and I was wondering if you could give
me some advice and how I can speak them
about this but still like in a
god-honoring way like what you would
recommend as my Uncle Dave how old are
you guys how long you been married good
for you very cool thank you well what I
would do is this I think the 401k
question starts to go away when you guys
get on the same page about your goals
and the shortest distance between where
you are in your goal let's so let's
start let's back up from the
conversation and not worry about the
details of the baby steps because right
now you have a little bit of information
about the baby steps and about all this
plans and details and all this and he's
got none and you've suddenly gotten
excited about building wealth you've
suddenly gotten excited about the money
thing and you never have been in 12
years and so he's kind of looking at you
like who are you now you're right on
track that's exactly what you do let's
get above this and say okay let's start
talking about I've been looking at this
money stuff and I'm getting excited
about it and so I want us to talk about
wealth I want to talk about how we can
build wealth so we can be outrageously
generous so we can change our family
tree and then once we both agree that
that we're working on towards that then
we can back up and say okay that's the
goal and then any time you set a goal
one of the next
questions you ask yourself whether you
realize it or not as you say okay what
has to be true that's not true now for
us to get there because if we were
already there we would already have all
the things dealing we're not there and
so there must be something wrong with
what we're doing and what's wrong with
what we're doing is we have debt and
because the number one the number one
process to building wealth the number
one thing to hit that goal is to be
debt-free
all the data tells us that all the
studies of millionaires that we've done
all the detailed data that we've drug
out of people over thirty years of doing
this the number one key to your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and once you understand that then
you say okay I got to get my income back
I can't be giving it all the banks then
the baby steps start to make sense
because you say okay before I start
investing I need to be able to invest
with gusto and I can't because I'm
walking with a limp carrying this debt
when you're paying a $500 car payment
that's $500 you can't put it into an
investment you're paying $300 on a
student loan that's been around so long
you think it's a pet that's $300 you
can't put it into an investment when you
have a master card who named that a
master card in your life then that's
money you can't put it into an
investment and so you're limited because
all the money comes in and most of money
goes out and the rest of it goes to the
401k and you're not getting there so all
the data tells us the shortest distance
between where you are and wealth is to
become debt free because that frees up
your most powerful will building tool
but if you start with that discussion
before you agree on the goal is building
wealth the purpose of building wealth of
course is change our family tree retire
with dignity and be outrageously
generous these are the things that
people build wealth for I want to make
sure my kids kids are taken care of I'm
taken care of I'm not a burden on my
family when I hit retirement and I can
help other people with money and the
more money I have the more other people
I can help with money
and so you know poor people can't feed
poor people that's a pretty basic
mathematical fact okay so
we're gonna try to be outrageously
generous we're gonna put ourselves in
this position to be generous and the way
to get there is get out of debts so that
we can invest with more gusto which gets
us there the fastest
now you might do it the other way you
might pull it off the other way but very
few people do the data tells us that the
people that get there the successful
people and if your husband's plan worked
you would already be there okay so his
plan isn't working because you're
diluting it you're trying to do two
things at once and you can't do two
things at once it's like people trying
to text and drive you know they can't do
they can't text well and they can't
drive well your your thumbs are all over
the place you're misspelling words and
you're swerving like a drunk you're
worse than a drunk and so you know you
just decide I'm not gonna try to do two
things at once you can't do two things
at once that's the problem and here's
the thing we're not ready saying stop
the 401k we're saying stop the 401k
temporarily and almost everyone is
debt-free except their house within two
years on this plan but that's if they
get gizelle intense and focused and stop
the 401k and take an extra job and live
on beans and rice and quit going on
vacations and don't see the inside of a
restaurant unless they're working there
during the two years you're completely
focused on getting out of debt without
I'm getting out so it's only two years
you're 30 to two years off of your 401k
it's not gonna keep you from being
wealthy mathematically it's simply not
and so take the time off and completely
focus don't text and drive
don't do it 401 K and try to get out at
the same time you're not gonna do either
one well that's what it comes down to
but if you start with I'm gonna talk
about your favorite subject the 401k and
I'm gonna call your baby ugly that's not
a plan that's like walking in and going
we're gonna get out of debt by selling
your truck darling
he's gonna go I'm not on your plan and
so you know you started with the white
instead of the Y and so go back and do
the Y the wealth building he's gonna be
receptive to that
he's already wired that way he's gonna
be happy
you're bringing this conversation up
start with that and then back down in
and then decide if you want to do this
the way that we teach as a couple you
can decide that this is not a cult you
can decide to not join the cult you can
decide to shave your head and drink the
kool-aid
but you don't have to and then you can
leave the cult later if you want so
we're really not a coal because coal
people don't leave they just stay once
they're there so you see what I'm saying
you get to decide what you're going to
do I give you the freedom to decide but
there are principles that work here and
if you want to do the proven plan and
not do it ish you'll get the best
results and that's what we're doing so
good question because that gives me a
chance to get up on my soapbox for
everyone out there